العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
خالفت توقعات
والسبب الصمود الاوكراني
توقعات كثيره رجحت سقوط كياف في غضون ايام
[موسيقى]
قياسا بقوه الجيش الروسي ثاني اقوى الجيوش
في العالم
السادس من فبراير 2022 رئيس هيئه الاركان
المشتركه الامريكيه
ستسقط في غضون اثنتين وسبعين ساعه اذا حدث
غزو روسي واسع النطاق لاوكرانيا
لكن الوضع لم يكن كذلك فما سر الصمودك
في الايام الاولى للمعارك اعتمدت اوكرانيا
على المتطوعين
[موسيقى]
كيف بتوزيع الاسلحه على المدنيين الراغبين
في القتال
الكثير من المدنيين استجابوا لنداءات
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
بعد الصمود في الاسابيع الاولى للحرب
تدفقت الاسلحه الغربيه فيما بعد
الاسلحه الغربيه اثرت كثيرا على مجريات
المعركه
العقوبات الغربيه ايضا شتت التركيز روسيا
التي كانت في مواجهه على العديد من
الجبهات
[موسيقى]